大家好
我是词人方文山
很欢迎
也很开心
大家来乐学课程选择了歌词创作班
那在接触这堂课之前
不管你在学校里有什么挫折
生活上有什么不如意
甚至情绪正处于低潮
这些都没关系
暂时搁置一旁
因为近期你做对了一件事情
就是报名的歌词创作班
这个歌词创作班呢
想给你带来一个投资报酬率最高的一个课程
什么叫投资报酬率最高的课程呢
很久以前我曾曾经在一些学校里面分享过阅读
因为就我而言
阅读就是投资报酬率最高的事情
怎么说
你想想看哦
一个人他绞尽脑汁
把他的所学所想集结成一本书
他跟田野调查了好几年
他可能旅游采风了好几年
集结成一本书
但是呢你只花了一杯咖啡
一个下午
就把这个人的知识累积化为己有
世界上没有比这个投资报酬率更高的事情了
而这个课程呢是累积我20几年来
对歌词创作的心得跟体验
所以呢这一堂视觉阅读
势必也将为一场投资报酬率最高的课程
那接下来我先大概的分享一下
课程里面有什么样的单元
第一个单元是对歌词应有的基本认识
再来是歌词创作中的基本训练
还有歌词技巧的进阶与强化
再来是实战经验的分享
还有最后一个单元是当一个有故事可以说的人
听起来很丰富吧
所以感到很热血
学
接下来我们先分享今天第一个单元
文学载体外的旁观者
听起来是不是很学术
好像是大学的一个论文的一个主标
你可以这么理解
就说歌词它的含义它可以很深很广
但是他的口语确实很浅显
很易懂
因为他必须跟你的情感做一个连接
所以歌词是很耐人寻味的一种作品
首先我们现在厘清文学
那文学到底是什么
文学就是对文字创作的一种记录跟累积
而这个累计的作品
它必须具备一定程度的艺术性跟内容的原创
他才够资格进入文学殿堂
那文学载体又是什么
文学载体呢就是承载文学创作一种形式
那这个形式有哪一些呢
有哪个类别呢
有四大类别
分别是小说
散文
诗歌跟剧本
这四个类别是文学创作的一个
大范围
那歌词呢歌词它的艺术性呢
他的原创性如何
歌词的原创性是有的
但艺术性的话有点小小的尴尬
因为歌词必须贴近人心
它必须通俗
它必须流行
所以它的遣词用语比较浅显
比较白话
也因此对我而言
歌词是文字作品
而不是文学作品
当然咯作为文字作品
你就只能在文学的范畴里面当个旁观者
但是这个旁观者的效应跟它辐射出去的影响力
却远远超过于诗歌
怎么说
诗歌是静态的文字作品
他服务的是个人一对一的吸收
但是歌词是因为旋律的结合
歌手的演唱
它辐射出去的影响力是非常非常的广泛
甚至于它可能是某一个时代的共同记忆
所以歌词的魅力在于此
虽然就我认为他可能语言的结晶度
不能进入文学殿堂
但是他的影响力却数倍于其他的文学作品
歌词是通俗文化的一环
不需要证照
不需要考试
你可以在第一时间听懂
看懂读懂的就叫做通俗文化
举凡电视电影戏剧
通俗小说
线上游戏
还有流行音乐
这些都是通俗文化的一环
也因此
歌词在通俗文化的范畴里面做最大的发挥
纵使它不是严格定义的文学作品
但是他的影响力有时候是超乎了一些文学
学作品
歌词依附着旋律跟歌手的演唱
而进入了通俗文化的一环
造就了他的强大影响力
好的接下来我们把话题拉回来
创作所有的创作就是跟这个世界在对话
每个有创作欲望的人
他的潜意识里面都是想要透过作品的媒介
跟这个世界有一个交流和对话
差别在于说你创作的媒介是什么
是影像吗
是图画吗
是声音吗
不管你的创作的媒介是什么
一定是在艺术的范畴里面
也就是所谓的八大艺术
其中有文学
戏剧绘画雕塑
音乐舞蹈建筑
还有第八艺术电影
你所有创作的人他都会有个发表欲
会有个成就感
你想要借由你的作品跟这个世界对话
你可能用一幅画去讲你的心情
用一段旋律去讲你最近的遭遇
用一个影像去表达你对这个世界的态度
所以创作是很特别的
他在跟这个世界对话
然后呢大家很喜欢看创作
看戏剧的原因是什么
其实因为每一个人人生都只有一条轨道
每个人只能扮演一次自己的性格
自己的人生
所以呢戏剧某种程度满足了我们潜意识里面
对不同角色的扮演
怎么说
我们很喜欢看那种所谓的黑帮电影
很热血很沸腾
很痛快淋漓的人生
像香港那种古惑仔
但是呢真实人生呢
你出去一个械斗
一个斗殴
不小心你可能手没了
可能残废了
这样子的人生没有人敢去赌
但是大多数的人会躲在荧幕后面
很安全的看一个热血沸腾的黑帮电影
你的角色情感会投射在那个戏剧上
所以呢不管是小说
戏剧还是电影
永远都有很多人在看
像很多知名的影集
譬如说冰与火之歌
因为大家喜欢看的原因是
因为每个人的人生只能有一条轨道
你只能有一种角色去走完你的人生
所以呢大家只能透过戏剧的角色
某种程度的弥补了你
角色扮演的一种潜在的渴望
所以戏剧小说电影永远都有人在看
大家只能活一辈子
你不可能去一下子是黑帮的特务
一家子是艺术家
一家子是金融的一个白领
不可能扮演这么多角色
所以戏剧迷人的地方在于说
他满足了每个人潜意识里面对不同人生的体验
跟一个角色扮演听起来是不是很过瘾
扮演不同的戏剧人生
是不是想要马上动笔从事创作
创作就是这么迷人
他可以凭空创作出一个世界来
像小说
像三体一个科幻小说
还有盗墓笔记
那是根本不存在的世界哦
可是竟有小说家的笔
他就是那戏剧里面的上帝
他塑形塑了各种的角色
各种的人物
各种的故事线
凭空创造出一个世界来
这个是文字创作者终身的一个追求的目标
像金庸
金庸的武侠小说真的有鹿鼎记韦小宝这个人吗
当然没有
笑傲江湖里面的令狐冲
或者是神雕侠侣里面的杨过跟小龙女
这个是他杜撰出来的人物啊
但是却活在我们心中
你就觉得说创作是多过瘾的事情
像哈利波特魔戒的中土世界
真的有中土世界吗
当然是没有
可是呢你借由观影的情绪感染你
具有想象力
具有戏剧的吸引
你宁愿相信有中土世界
因为很迷人
有精灵
有矮人
有半兽人
有强兽人
多么一个热血沸腾
戏剧张力很强的一个世界
像哈利波特里面的霍格沃茨魔法学院
难道称to这个魔法学院吗
但是没有
但是小说家居然能借由他的笔形
塑出一个我们认为或者是希望存在的世界
这个就是创作最迷人的地方
各位同学
你们选择这堂课是对的
因为呢你们可以拥有一个可以留下作品的人生
可以留下作品的人生是很幸福的
是很过瘾的
因为一个不存在的事物
一个不存在的世界
经由你的创作
经由音乐
经由歌词
经由小说
经由任何形式的一种艺术创作
甚至于经由电影的一个传播
甚至于他的拍摄行塑出你脑海中的一个世界
这是非常过瘾的事情
每个人都只能有一种人生
一条生活的轨道
言子创作迷人的地方就在这里
我们可以借由想象力
借由创造力行说出一个原本不存在的世界
这是何其的痛快
何其的迷人
所以你选择这个课程是对的
因为我们将在这26堂课里面一起成长
一起历练
一起经历所有跟创作相关的事情
因为创作是迷人的
创作是精彩的
创作是可以留下人生风景的
让我们一起拥有一个可以留下作品的人生